here we go pick it up pick it up
I got it man that's Jesus
you're way too little to be telling
people what to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
everybody's good to go right
someone said that you were a snake cuz
you say that it lets coax uses comes
cook steals your kills or something I
don't know so wait how do we do this do
we do it says knife Falls rain do we
want to do should we do prestige regular
knife all first Oh
McLovin says hello Eric hello mclovin
let me tweet now it's I'm broadcasting
enough three viewers right now you
shouldn't have any viewers goddammit
I know he's got more of me did you guys
watch Fahrenheit 451 I'm halfway through
it no not yet no I mean again I mean I
like it I don't know I'm torn I got to
finish it before I give my final
thoughts but it looks good I mean it
looks good the performances are good
what's up Syd see mom
I'm excited for that
beyond human I like those games okay so
how do you tweet again I forgot
how do you tweet no no no I'm talking
about from that destiny from the app
know that I don't know [ __ ] okay here we
go share to Twitter all this [ __ ]
life falls hard as hell it's 271 yeah
this is a hard strike we could turn this
volume down yeah oh [ __ ] we can let we
should have got on our [ __ ] sparrows
not too late I like running around it's
nice to see the scenery this one's
really hard but we don't have to deal
with this [ __ ]
oh you mean don't come home
no yeah we could I guess we need points
but we just wasn't really this we came
we just want to get something good from
what City College when we don't do it
again all right all right I sought
Deadpool do you guys see Deadpool yes no
I haven't seen it is it good fights for
people about I told my friend at
infinity war it's not gonna be the
biggest grossing movie of all time it's
not even gonna do better than debt bin
black dancer you know Deadpool's Conan
you know
[ __ ] getting it Griffin what oh I jump
off the mountain I messed up what are
you guys doing holy fog forgot this was
my year to respect the nightfall watch
out I'm coming hold on Pikachu - okay
you're back
hey get over here just [ __ ] those guys
god damn that guy was so hard to kill
lice these [ __ ] [ __ ] up here that
are [ __ ] us up though these guys are
the worst
now let's team shoot that night up there
we get around this I'm gonna go around
here I'm gonna try to get up to him
quick cuz shit's stupid we get up there
this way yeah right yeah you can you
could just jump remember we have to kill
that night so we could get to have the
thing to blow that that night right
there see it you have to kill that night
oh my god I think time I'm going the
wrong way
oh [ __ ] do something what's wrong with
this nightfall Wow is the only way to go
that's my graviton oh [ __ ] a [ __ ]
junkie [ __ ] are on my tail man [ __ ] man
peace can you get me out
yeah let me just kill these all right
they're gonna kill me in Griffin don't
worry I'm trying to get this [ __ ] guy
yeah okay God oh thank you
there we go there we go
I don't know if I should rocket launcher
my times a rocket launcher yeah these
yellow guys for sure oh did you just
knock them all off something off fell
off
hot damn God thank you break our needs
don't kill them nothing now
[ __ ] oh there's another one he
started a lot of HP yeah because we have
to kill both we have to kill - because
it's the nightfall now are there because
there's more like if you do this by
yourself there's only one night but when
you have when you have three people
gotta stop nah Chris well you know what
to me I'm gonna [ __ ] go to a rocket
launcher cuz this is not gonna get the
job done
we should go slide the right applause
and a lot for the boss
yeah this boss is hard as hell to beat
that odor and then you have to beat
another final boss yeah really don't
don't drop down like an [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] yeah okay
[ __ ] me see that's why I've never done
bad well I killed Muslims to do there
are most of our death
she's literally that one night left this
[ __ ] die
I know dude we're both shooting at him
what's up maximize any damage just think
what Steve is gonna be on a little bit
yeah he's doing it he's doing a patreon
stuff and then they love you they love
Wow Joey's podcast person yeah see that
yeah I just talked to Joey tonight
yeah Joey's a cool dude I want to do
Rogen's podcast on the 4th oh nice
alright obviously yeah how did Frank do
it before you blew your title
Loic we live
I'm gonna use my hammer on these guys
that's miss Forbes I can't even get the
guy I mean wow dude these nights are so
hard I mean it's supposed isn't it like
370 light level or 350 no like this like
hard I'm back in the funk out - they're
coming hard
oh [ __ ] I'm dead oh yeah maybe you guys
should switch so not dying I'm just
kidding how dare you yeah yes yes go get
Griffey go get Griffin okay I can
respawn on my own
all right Griffin's here Griffin's here
I mean so you can't kill anything with
your guns and it takes forever
we still shut down the prestige right
that would be great
no [ __ ]
that night that wizard isn't dead yet
oh my god okay team shooter I'm getting
drift enough team shoot the same stuff
guys
yeah we've had to kill all the apples oh
oh [ __ ] okay a lot of ads are coming and
suiciders but I don't think I don't fit
behind by the way do we kill the Wizards
we're gonna kill us but I gotta sit in
this little fire to get my Ruger Navy
back faster hold up okay cool I can make
it suppose this dis recharges all my
[ __ ] when I do this that's cool there
you go or we can go you know I kind of
feel like a sniper rifle is good for
this this god the other Darcy it's
really good yeah but that oh gosh he's
only good when you're using a warlock
why does that anybody else use it
[ __ ] this night it's just they're
cutting of the fields the shields make
it ten times worse yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
just distract this take hey can we team
football mind around the left so we
gotta kill this other ogre yeah yeah
yeah we gotta kill this oh c'mon a lot
alright alright put another referee is
he don't waste ammo it's never wasting
like I'm getting it back
like they don't kill these [ __ ]
nights with her stupid shields we got we
got we got we gotta shoot you die she
tonight she tonight you tonight soon
though he's guys shield up
watch out watch out that over in the
middle of I got a feed on this that
[ __ ] night man I know so that's why
I'm doing this I'm gonna put this up to
distract this over okay now you shooting
at me so go get him trying dude all
right yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
run it with my [ __ ]
I think you should pick it up I got a
run back
hold on Giotto I got that night get up
well whoever has it throw it up the
greens turn wait wait hold on I want to
get my gray bag okay there we go we got
one over let's go back let's go back to
this I heard that leather night back
there I'm sure she'll do lover it also
yoga's gonna come first the season way
hard for [ __ ] it's a night falsify
know what I'm saying like that's what
I'm saying I know what are you saying
I'm saying how you guys do me ball good
to see you what's up chat look how many
nights we have to kill just to kill this
piece of [ __ ] thing this is this like
this is a emboss right here you know
what I mean yeah should be fun how did I
miss that dude where's that bad he's
nice
back in mad I'm shooting this guy back
here
I'd almost got him hey could we go we
got we got blown
here we go pick it up pick it up I got
it man that's easy
you're a way too little to be telling
people what to do oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die
I'm getting oh [ __ ] I'm dead dude that
night came out nor I can backup Peaks
where is the Aussie I see what you are I
see where you're at I won't even get me
just I'll respond in 12 seconds imagine
if you couldn't respond remember how to
hold my oh yeah my fall was well that
happened with the boss remember that
happens with the boss oh [ __ ] with the
worst grenade burst walking in the HBO
product I'm back I'm back
this [ __ ] night dude he is like
hiding behind his [ __ ] rod
well coming around oh [ __ ] there's a
dude up there he's [ __ ] me up
hold on peace I'll get you up yeah I'll
Griffin you're [ __ ] over there so
stupid Oh about to die load my rocket
launcher I had it I gotta come over here
and close dude yeah [ __ ] you John I know
you're off the phone I told you I'm
podcasting [ __ ] - [ __ ] - weapons do
more you know when he's so right about
the art web you know I know what I'm
gonna get I know what I'm gonna get
Louie I need to like switch out of this
well second he's coming after me he's
almost dead I think Taylor's works I'll
tell you works work school with this is
the risk runner I got oh my god yeah
responder Stella good
all right I took down a shield all right
here we go
I took down a shield I'm gonna run
around look for purple ammo cuz I ain't
got a my oh [ __ ]
put a wrong spot [ __ ] okay did you
get him down
yeah oh [ __ ] no way is there one more
[ __ ] shot another night yeah just one
more he's better nights way back here
I'm coming back to you got him
every loading my heavy this [ __ ]
night died already
Jesus Christ hey keep that thing yep all
right sit down now the big the big night
is loose now the big overflows yeah
and he does not [ __ ] around nice
Pikachu's
there we go we get oh yes good job peaks
all right let me pick up all this heavy
yeah yeah we need all this
we built this heavy so good okay
I'm trying to think fresh to switch to a
sniper rifle oh I should not have did
something so stupid I [ __ ] got rid of
that sniper oh my god I'll dance for you
I wonder if I should try sniper right
you know what I'll never - already have
heavy I'll switch later all right let's
go you know what's great with this is
like a risk runner works great with this
because when a Thrall hit you they are
they are arc so that it activates the
arc thing you know what I mean
oh yeah let's go hurry up
yeah I'm coming I'm coming I had to
Texas duties drive them off what much is
driving me nuts
oh we're gonna get back to my chat I can
read your chat I have it open to Mercy
will demolish everything though it was
oh wait yeah we got it
here we go camping it's a lot an easy
fight now is gonna be hard as [ __ ] oh my
god they're [ __ ] shields jeez I know
but I'm [ __ ] love with the wrists
oh yeah right switch I think I'm gonna
switch to my heart light switch to my
heart you know what I want to screw out
all I can say shut up get up you know
give me out give me out wait let me just
using my hammer
custom use my super glad you told me
I mean the Hammers don't do enough
damage that's [ __ ] bananas dude oh
this boss is [ __ ] bananas is the boss
okay mom I use all your like [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] yeah we should spread out we
shouldn't stay in the same place so he
can he doesn't center all his fire and
one okay here comes the ads here we go
this is the part that sucks really more
than him ours now has my ads
use a masterworks weapon so we get more
orb okay yeah
look at that already got
I already got my Superman and we
according the or baby
I'm gonna save my super for when there's
gonna be a lot of ads there we go all
right I'm gonna take out this knife
quick
I thought I was are using a tweezer the
same gun [ __ ] he's down but I'll pick it
up pick it up a little bit
I got it I got it I'm gonna throw it
like me no we should okay nevermind
doesn't matter I get these orbs
zoinks
oh you got it I got it
you guys ready to move you throw it yet
I mean it's like it matter all of this
hold on she's gonna grab stuff I got
heavy [ __ ] right so angry oh yeah
I want to go hammers [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is gonna be hard to be it's
the next one that says he's gonna start
moving around and shooting he already is
I mean gonna start yeah are you dead
yeah I'll get out of this peak I got oh
Jesus Christ
I'll get him I'll get on with slack yeah
I'm coming I'm coming just Oh get out
get out he'll rise when it killed [ __ ] I
got there for no-one get grooving I'm
down go go go
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh you're talking
shitty you're down
I just got [ __ ] Pikachu up in the
middle of the house for you go down well
I just got a flight in ground scared the
[ __ ] out of me okay there we go
ammo on this Iceland out of these
[ __ ] these I want to switch to my
Darcy but I can't [ __ ] take out this
wizard I'm trying to tell ya [ __ ] think
it's so easy
I know and then did you just rise rape
does wizard check out this wizard and
then I'm say [ __ ] I'll try to
get these Griffin although okay got
that's why as our not me I'm getting him
off
our Wizards down going for this night
okay half my freaking
oh [ __ ] I'm hurt
all right I got that guy down you got it
oh my god just blow it just thought well
don't worry I get out with it I know I
know the [ __ ] you
I know do baby Chu Chu Xiu Qi just give
me up he said [ __ ] goddamnit you guys
are rough no nights almost dead
alright that's all you Peaks I got it I
got it cookie Brown
but I gotta get this
come on we got to do more damage on this
Park you trying
make any orbs working hard to make orbs
I'm just gonna make [ __ ] but kill
these stars yeah there we go
nice nice he's [ __ ] them here [ __ ] me
little bit next time yeah I'm going
there but now he's gonna move he's gonna
move around down yeah yes I don't
because oh there's some orbs see
I need this orb then I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here so we don't all died on
the area yeah yeah yeah exactly
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I love that grenade
where are your fetus back there all
right hold on back there yeah I don't
know if I can get to you hold on [ __ ]
you can't get to me I did I did but get
out get out get out get out just get out
of there all this [ __ ] sites right
there all peaks of pose oh my god not
getting Pikachu just got a require she's
[ __ ] me up would you get out of there
you should have run toward Griffin watch
out the lights right there all right get
me up get me up Pete I got a guy's job
I can't believe I survived that oh my
god I can't breathe right now sweating
stop dying
I can't do it those no more of I mean
there go get out get out [ __ ] get home
yeah yes get out of there oh my god run
what are you doing get out of there
you're like hitting the night
oh [ __ ] just run run around run all the
way around pull all the way around we
got 7 seconds apart go die 4 seconds
keep on it
I like everything's it's hilarious we're
almost at the end this [ __ ] guy he
dies and he goes hits a [ __ ] night
well we're all dead
oh [ __ ] we got him we haven't even
touched that other [ __ ]
oh my god oh can i activate my wrist
runner
come on active I swear to God Pikachu
what are you doing over there all right
here we go I got I got it alright watch
out watch out oh my god I'm in I'm
coming too I'm up in 70 seconds yeah I'm
just gonna wait I'm not gonna get you I
can't just leave it there
I got I got great fun I got Griffin all
right go get Griffin give me up I'll get
the thing
alright you got it you put the oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's right here go go go
shoot it there we go alright he's down
nice Peaks there you go no I just saw to
walk it at nothing we definitely are the
worst fire team ever asked
we definitely live up to the name I'll
tell you that [ __ ] I got big surprise
like I care you died here we go y'all
you know my god this thing hit me
so close to my super what is oh my god
can't believe it didn't die like get the
[ __ ] out of here we gotta kill him
here we go here we go here we go we got
it we got it Jew don't shoot don't shoot
them yes and you want to do perceive
yeah we do well but you know but you do
procedure you get like a burn you know I
mean yeah oh yeah you get that close
good job guys I can't pick up that line
let me erase one of these emblems oh boy
actually wasn't I don't think it was
that hard in comparison
maybe comparison to would like I think
that one cabal cuz ball one is harder oh
the green one that shoots the sniper
rifle all right can't find my freaking
Darcy well here it is now you could do
the prestige go to the tower we go to
the tower
[Music]
I think Griffin I think you should get
an assistant out manage your destiny
loot
god [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay yeah I got I don't know I can't
tell how many people are watching the
stream though doesn't say nine people I
might be go on nine people well that's
nothing
I'm sorry for the two that are watching
me right now let's go see what we can
get
I like when Pikachu's yelling and then
he dies that's my favorite thing
why aren't you guys yeah yeah yeah you
guys should and then he's dead great you
know let me edit this now I can make my
thing oh yeah there we go there you go
be nice to Steve got on though he can do
some 4v4 alright it's two on two or
something oh god I don't want to do two
on two is Steve he'll get so angry if I
kill him like I don't think he gets more
mad than when I shoot him he's he's a he
even says it enrages him he goes like
super resume message okay that's so cute
we got here oh my god it's not good wait
now you know what I'm gonna just first
I'll see what I have there yet has to
happen
where is her he's at our right here yeah
and then you can um it's got the suros
sir oh yeah you didn't deserve it us
from destiny one oh really
it's exotic auto-rifle 45 arms alright
kids and then yeah that was the original
that was the og original wine yeah
that's why yes 351 yes
hold on I'll just let me get rid of some
[ __ ] for anything grinded Peaks no I got
like a thank you and welcome to ever VAS
useless piece of [ __ ] vendor thanks for
shopping ever that's Guardian thanks for
dropping she was a volatile you have
survived when I get home and I got
nothing dude piece of [ __ ] stuff man
it's always a light level yeah check the
light levels what's gonna be your higher
level though that's what you want you
know what yeah you're right you're right
let me see this this one is so much
better this sniper rifle is so much
better so now I'm going to infuse first
let's make it a postmaster get so filled
up so quickly oh [ __ ] my new person but
maybe I should me yes maybe I'm 350 I
want this I want there so what this is a
good sniper rifle good sniper rifle
alright oh [ __ ] look at this 349 I got
some 349 [ __ ] you know what you know
what you know what scope dope for the
Titan is the AC DC's AC whatever those
things are suckers these suckers are
great and like night in crucible - yeah
yeah people are always trying to like
yeah okay I know once I was good
he's gonna tell me he passed out again
but that's like two nights in a row or
something well he's got a lot going on
man he was in uh ya know relationship I
think he's I think he's drinking man I
think he's on the bottle he's on the
sauce got to get him off
ventures oh is he like drinking about it
I don't know I mean he was posting a lot
of weird stuff like posting stuff and
then deleting that oh Jesus
just you know I hope he doesn't become
like one of those TMZ stories no no
let's hope he doesn't like Colin
MacGregor and [ __ ] you said the other
night he was on Griffin and he was waste
fellows we could try to prestige now but
make it mark make it art please
yeah yeah yeah I got a new hard light is
a higher light level whoo 53 nice this
one can you switch the 356 Porsche right
wait is it always wait okay arc solar
legs can be some cross legs [ __ ] yes
yes yes they are can make an arc weapon
yeah dude now I mean Sun Nanami
all right let me switch it up then maybe
I should switch to this is gonna melt
yeah risk for an hour melts man all
right hold on yeah let me go to my vault
I gotta get something heavy for her I
gave her I thought his up
ooh I have how do you see what I got
here
hey I'm dude you see what is this 3:40 I
mean want your 3:40 [ __ ] I already
got this let me save that though alright
oh [ __ ] I'm already done I got
everything I need alright I'm ready
alright give me one sec got it god it's
welcome I just don't have any good art
heavy weapons that aren't then don't
worry about it if I'm talking about it
already alway do you guys do you have
that ghost
you know what ghost you should use is
the one that is generally good detects
can't oh yeah I don't I don't have it on
this character I gotta get rid of some
of these [ __ ] ghosts let me get rid
of [ __ ]
you should Swit there there this exotic
ghost or you use energy weapons and you
get more you can Lola you get more your
I think wait I need to get the perks
it's like your grenades go faster or
something like that it's one of those
yeah I don't have that one I got a bunch
of [ __ ] ghosts alright it's just one
my chest right okay let's see oh your
vehicle takes less time to summon who
cares generate gunsmith tell entry data
on any elemental weapon kills yeah i got
the photo yes I thought that was good
and it's not made a big deal out of
nothing
alright you guys ready let's go yeah
yeah I'm ready now I master work my
sixth yeah I got my god a 350 348 right
now and my three 15s so I believe Jesus
Jesus Christ yeah you're gonna die if I
tell arts art singe right that's correct
oh yeah all right you make you like now
we're never gonna do this alright people
watching we're about to do prestige
night all oh [ __ ]
this dude says use the top tree of the
Sun breaker it does way more damage
Griffin whatever I'll just tell that guy
for opinions as well you should just say
[ __ ] your opinions yeah yeah sorry to
the phase whatever how about mine
how about mind your business
oh I forgot we can't change weapons mid
oh wow I forgot about that it's weapons
lock oh we're clawed we're not gonna
make it past the first yeah we're [ __ ]
I know I agree there's no way or making
it past that first over got it's so
[ __ ] hot in my living room right now
I know I know
yeah I open my window and put the fan on
it's warm lately okay yeah right I'm not
my couch like sweating through my shorts
yeah but that's just cuz look at you
makes you upset then my ears are [ __ ]
sweating because of this thing yeah I
know exactly what you mean I get it too
it's been a hot [ __ ] lately every
night I get it open my window
well my neighbor found bones in the
backyard doesn't even rhyme they were
buried at the back
no bones and you know I don't really
talk to them we kind of on the outs but
they came in their life we need you to
look at these bones and give us your
opinion all died already I'm not doing
I'm not I don't trust no so what we get
in the game you guys are dead we didn't
face an enemy here get up
Wes cuz I realized I had to turn I jump
you know you know what just mind your
business mind your business
yeah get you a shirt that says that I
like that oh what the [ __ ]
what happened Pikachu went ahead too far
and he died or something oh really it's
returned to orbit what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] yeah okay sure ever yeah don't [ __ ]
around dude oh yeah dude this is like
serious business the worst so anyway
they found bones in the backyard and and
there but it's like pieces of bones
they're like what do you think you think
it's an animal I was like [ __ ] I don't
know
I'm not paleontologist and then so I
took her to that I took the neighbor to
the police station he's brought it back
[ __ ] bones to the police woman behind
the desk and she opens it up and she's
like she's like what is this and we're
like bones and she's like oh I'm not
taking this she's like you could call
the coroner
so they gotta wait till tomorrow to call
the coroner to see if oh no feels like a
dead body in your we have a dead body
hippies a crazy did you do Craig what if
it was the ghost of Steven Lee like he
was never really here it was all just as
ghosts
know what they're gonna do is they're
gonna end up like questioning everybody
and like you know seeing who it is and
checking motives and yeah well the thing
is it would have been like from fifty
years ago like the bones are old as [ __ ]
Oh dinosaur bones making a murderer
with Craig anyway the Craig was only 11
years old back then I was only 11 1930
you could be a murderer later now but so
the foot but the thing is that was funny
is like I was like oh they're dinosaur
bones you guys might be rich don't share
that news dinosaur bones we live in LA
we're right by the Tar Pits no but it's
not gonna be that to be honest I didn't
dig that deep so it's not going to be
dinosaur probably just somebody's
probably somebody's dog you know that's
what I'm thinking but good art it's true
but some of the bones were really large
look like a piece of a hip bones secret
together hell aren't tripping you're
tripping you're tripping
I guess a this burden is actually making
me fall yeah yeah this sniper rifles
beast with the burn yeah like I legit I
have to like make sure my being [ __ ]
not yeah because you should just do that
in general Pikachu's not just when we
play this yeah yeah yeah yeah don't die
yeah period yeah you try that piece of
cheese
goddamn these [ __ ] guys in there
[ __ ] schist guys so [ __ ] hard to
kill man my god Oh trying to shoulder
charge him yeah not fun [ __ ] dear no I
wasn't alright I killed that night I'm
not accolade I'm gonna move on
girlfriend about it
yeah go ahead I'm what I go for this
night I'm gonna keep this night busy
oh one shot one shot in that dude
[ __ ] killed me holy yeah because it's
the only problem when you do arc is
everything else is arc also so you so
we've we've we've helped them to you
know dogs by means everybody gets
heartburn thank you that's why I always
felt like it better to do like two shots
and I was done I wasn't even two shots
today I don't know what that did hit me
with it was one shot yep there you go
you got to get some distance on a
Pikachu there's too close too
goddamn how long does a [ __ ]
take
oh this is gonna take even longer yeah
dude this is gonna be forever I say we
try to pick it to the ogre and see if we
can get past that dude cuz it's just
gonna be ridiculous Jesus Christ man
yeah I don't think we should be [ __ ]
around these enemies yeah but we have to
get points to like doesn't matter I
don't know if we can get past them you
know what I mean like I think you know
one shot from these dudes oh [ __ ] we
just got it low we just holy [ __ ] we
just got a coordinator super we used to
coordinate our attack so then we don't
have he's not even he's not even a
yellow god oh my god oh my god let's do
this let's check out those Sooners
that was [ __ ] I was not that close
that guy did for the boss fight we
should have a tether we don't have one
okay this is gonna be fun
bleep up guys we're gonna do great
even those [ __ ] snipers do
yeah shoot those guys at the top up
there yeah okay here we go
ouch ouch ouch okay now we got to get
this guy oh Christ man this is serious
I don't think it's done I took out a
bunch of my super buddy gonna be hard it
is supposed to be we are supposed to be
360
but Steve is watching us right now just
laughed at my deeds [ __ ] haha
I don't think so he's drawing right now
I don't know he likes to watch sometimes
when he know when he draws just like his
own bro
oh you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me dude
sounds [ __ ] [ __ ]
it wasn't even the guy close to me it's
that other [ __ ]
Oh oh my god watch out watch out see
shots you're dead let's do some
multiplayer I don't know I had a shield
I don't know I was reviving them and
then it killed me still it was stupid
yeah it was fun while it lasted let's do
some multi players get I will get some
team wins touch my fear up
yeah I want to switch my gear up - [ __ ]
man yeah we couldn't I just too much
this switch it up all right
let me know you guys are ready I'm ready
all right let's do it should we do well
we tried it we tried the thing and it
didn't work our people watching yeah
I'll play a couple of Shalimar oh yeah
are you done with this a new show or is
this the same no no one more day
sign up here oh nice Marty we already
did that party was yesterday oh that's
always kind of sister to hit ya know
especially after seeing everybody how
they were acting at the wrap party
yesterday
hey you see them today yeah yeah I know
that goes yeah I always think it's weird
when they do the wrap party before the
end of the show it's like you still got
a hangout mm-hmm yeah I like these new
maps some of these new maps yeah some
control using my new cheat weapon the
graviton Lance really is that good that
gun it is so bad
I got a double down with that last guy
got me yeah dude you haven't tried it
yet Griffin Griffin you got it no it's
what everybody's using it's the meta
it's just like literally it's like three
shots especially like two head shots
it's ridiculous I'm getting C by myself
oh [ __ ] we're about to have power playas
gonna see but they're coming for C and
it have a lot of time oh my god this is
so annoying
who's pushing meat [ __ ] goddamn
head [ __ ]
most pushes oh man another taking a nice
haha
how's that guy still alive [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god there's a guy with a colony be
careful I can't even get over this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] in the back oh
they're doing good for like two point
two seconds fine it's fine
oh my god I [ __ ] feel worse foreign
aid doing great so far
alright they're gonna come for me I'm
taking C now hold on [ __ ] did that guy
come into a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here well we
have fired things this [ __ ] guy get
that heavy Griffin Wow [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't want to see me put a fusion rifle
you don't want to see me with a fusion
rifle
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up like that like the
attitude was oh no place to hide so
they've lost
he captured Zone B you have advantage
okay I just took that dude out oh Jesus
Christ
you're welcome get out of the way I just
[ __ ] killed the daybreak yelling at
me sound seed lost somebody who's that
that's me oh [ __ ] I almost made to see
pika behind you what are you doing that
wasn't even me oh my god hey dude I was
getting kills I notice you're doing
Peaks I'm getting kills too up who's on
top of the leaderboard right now hi
Griffin
oh there's a sword dude take a look and
I'll hold these zones very long get
another zone Jesus I got [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you up right [ __ ] you Craig oh man
damn that overthrew that grenade
this guy's loved my [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
oh my god the the chick I'm getting
killed by the Jade rabbit that's
embarrassing
no they did but they popped all that
[ __ ] they bumped it to I'm always
picking on you and it's all sick and
[ __ ] is gonna sick okay I feel bad what
a hard time you know yeah yeah get it
girl then I want to go let's go and see
what I think I kill you God dang it
she's [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go right there
oh my god I'm going back for this [ __ ]
take the big maps it's like [ __ ] hard
how are we losing I feel like we're
taking be like we've helped be forever
it's just well my god there's a sword
there's a sword there's not anymore
[ __ ] the [ __ ] colony you piece of
[ __ ] - hey break watch out
[ __ ] Dave ring hi-yah
[ __ ] oh that was beautiful we just
cleared hey they're getting in there
getting a [ __ ] colony man oh yeah you
have so the doctors get up come up come
up come up come up come up
oh my god
I got him
I took that [ __ ] I'm away I live
in it so they captured
well I'm trying dude there's two guys
don't see gotta get keep let's go be
it's gonna be because nice get them with
hammers nice dude that dudes what I've
taught you don'ts a good shotguns dad
tracer cannon one the tractor cannon
okay we're tied
they have three super heavy why I threw
a grenade what the [ __ ] happened there
oh my god yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] get
impeached get him ah damn it I don't
know what I was doing right there just
looking like a complete nincompoop get
them yeah you oh let's get a kill we're
gonna get some kills get that B oh yes
watch out
all right staff art stuff why was [ __ ]
out I'm shooting at them no who's whose
[ __ ] is that was
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]